hello and welcome to this video playing
Lord Jim that's zero and bosh probably
not pronouncing this correctly here
would not probably not your room no
anyway um we had some games some time
ago I think he placed the old Indian no
not this one so probably the NIMS oh
let's see what he goes for he's a good
theoretician so I don't expect to get
something particularly brilliant in the
opening d5 yeah this is an interesting
option that I never looked at and this
could cost me okay but well I'm going
with a simple simple position are you
come on he will take now alas and we
have this this position typical of the
names of Quincy to wear white has some
chance is still to play for the minority
attack in that card spot structure okay
97 maybe he wants to go to d6 quickly
this might be six bishop I want two nite
CH or something if I castle a castle he
will probably play Bishop g4 maybe 95
when I place got 25 doesn't really can
do much
hmm i don't want him to trade so easily
hmm
maybe still this I don't know how he
just goes back yet trading us rather
simplistic but I don't know if I have
much more I can go here this is not so
bad
okay night over to e4 is so i can put
put this up you know Bishop f5 i guess
and 94 yeah it's not it's not much I
mean it's not like I have a huge edge or
something but um I'd really i didn't
know that opening well and didn't want
to go for some super sharp auction
yeah probably have to move the rook here
after some 94 takes Bishop takes Queen
g5 I need Bishop f1 so I can it's not a
bad idea to do that prophylactically so
it's going forward is six and then
possibly some sacrifice c5 immediate
claim now let's sacrifice I have f4 dome
I always have f4 huh I can play a
foursome like rookie six takes Bishop g2
okay he just captures which is not bad I
just didn't see I didn't see that idea
it's very simple of course but as I
still didn't see it didn't see that
soon
hi Scott it just has a six and we'll
cover all that I it's not so easy to
move the corn stall so easy now just
blundered that be five it's really just
a blunder
okay at least you can also easily move
the pods as I mentioned earlier very
unnecessary though
move the bishop around to be three
damn it i should have played rock c3
earlier
maybe stupid
Skye gasps be five this could be five
him ah I really hate that game really
hoping to getting you 2,500 again and
then I have placed such a stupid game
here really completely unnecessary very
stupid loss very likely a loss
yeah I've learned the pawn and then hi
morning then allowed this this Bishop d3
even though without that it wasn't even
that clear probably losing of course but
at least I can fight
yes before now
can you play be two
between wins and they all been
unfortunately
yeah I what a bad game design really
hate this game okay b5 it just takes it
they're very very that's just totally
stupid play I can do whatever I mean
it's not saying nothing happens it's
just a normal position and then even
here I mean I just have to play rook c3
and prevent this this stuff yeah just
this is just the geotech totally idiotic
if I play something like this this is
still a pretty difficult technical task
I think at least I can maybe go here and
do the same thing now it's also not good
time I mean I wasn't implying a thing
I'm bad or anything just felt that I
could put up a better resistant but b5
is utterly stupid and also totally
unnecessary I mean I can just play for
whatever now the soft place not making
the Moose what happens and so this this
this and just just prepare it or what I
mean nothing nothing going on here yeah
it could be five just just a normal
position he's got this this initiative
here this is blundering a piece he's
making those moves I'd seen that one
yeah just a piece down rights it's an
equal position I think nothing nothing
terrible would be five it's just
terrible I just give him a pawn for no
reason whatsoever okay so let's go for
the next game thanks for watching